hello and welcome to the Sheehy's aren't
you so the plan for this video was to
repeat this book quietly sleep but
unfortunately if any got about halfway
through it so far I mean I honestly read
up I'm not gonna lie
keep falling asleep whenever I try to
read it so I've already learned so much
anyway so I felt obliged to share a few
some of the nuggets of knowledge that
I've already learned and mainly in this
video we're going to focus on sleep and
the relationship to weight loss mainly
because it's the chaps that I've just
read and it's pretty interesting so
hopefully by the end of this video
you'll be able to understand this graph
here a bit better and the relationship
between the amount of sleep and weight
loss or weight gain so I think there's a
bit of a myth out there that if you
sleep for a shorter period of time such
that you're weak for longer you have the
opportunity to burn more calories and
therefore you're more likely to lose
weight than if you sleep more well
obviously if you were going to run a
marathon instead of sleeping well for
thirsty congratz a marathon that's quite
an achievement but also yes you would
lose more weight than if you decided to
sleep but the evidence we have now is to
kind of share that that just really
isn't the case and that the less you
sleep the more likely you are to eat but
as we'll see it's not just about the
amount of food that you eat it's also
how the body responds to you the food
that you eat and what foods that it
craves in the first place so what
evidence do we have this what there's
been numerous studies i've tried to
investigate this relationship and so one
example that's given in the book is they
had a group of healthy adults and they
slept for four hours for six nights and
at the end of it they were 40% less
effective at absorbing a standard days
of glucose and so this effectively has
caused these healthy adults to go into a
pre-diabetic State now whilst this is
already quite an alarming statistic to
make matters worse when you're tired you
tend to eat more as well and that's
partly due to the change in two very
important hormones that's controlling
your hunger and your appetite and so
these two home
ah leptin and ghrelin so when you feel
fill up you'll have higher levels of
leptin in your body whereas when you
feel hungry you'll have high levels of
ghrelin but the problem is when you're
sleep-deprived what happens is that the
levels of leptin which would normally
stimulate and tell your body that you
feel full actually decreases and what
happens is you see an increase in the
levels of ghrelin which make you feel
hungry and so these two hormones have
partially antagonizing roles within the
body and if you wanna know more about
the genetics and the biochemical basis
this have a previous video when it's all
ready so how does this relate to weight
gain or weight loss well it comes down
to a simple equation of energy and
fastens energy out if you've got more
energy coming in then coming out and it
will results in weight gain and so we've
already seen that being sleep-deprived
increases your calorie intake but not
only does it increase your intake but
you may also see a decline in your
energy expenditure and that partly
becomes comes from the fact that you
become lethargic when you are
sleep-deprived and so maybe because
you've got marathan on your first night
but if you want them to do that every
night it just wouldn't be the case I
just want to point out her as well but I
have no idea what I've drawn up in that
little left-hand corner that it kind of
looks like a cloud with a McDonald's
logo in it or a lightning strike mmm
clearly not a very good artist I don't
know I've got it I think it means a
perfect storm yes it means a perfect
storm of the fact that you've got the
increase in expenditure and decrease in
no increase in take decrease expenditure
anyway adding to this perfect storm is
the fact that you also see changes in
brain activity when you have an
individual that is sleep deprived say
what they did in this study is they took
against them healthy average weight
participants and they showed them a
number of cards of different freedom
shades ranging from fruit and veg to
more unhealthy snacks such as ice cream
pasta and donuts
I think pastas quite hot anyway and so
whilst we good Thursday looks at the
brain activity of the participant
and what they thought was that in the
sleep-deprived group they saw that there
was why they would normally be high
activity in the prefrontal cortex which
is part of the brain for thoughtful
judgment and controlled decision-making
it was silenced when they last sleep and
instead they saw and activated primal
deep brain structures and so what this
led to was high calorie feed becoming
more desirable to things he felt
sleep-deprived so if we came back to the
graph that I introduced at the start of
this video which I've also just taken
straight from the book what's been
plotted on this graph is literally the
average amount of sleep that has been
recorded for the past 50 years and also
the percentage of obese individuals in
the u.s. over the same time period and
you can see the observed trends or
correlation that as the average sleep
amount has declined there's been a
corresponding increase in the percentage
of obese individuals now whilst this is
just a correlation and correlation
doesn't always be in causation is so
pretty remarkable to see it plotted like
this and as we've seen from the studies
as well that there's been a lot of
evidence supporting a link between the
two and I haven't even finished yet
because later on in this chapter it goes
on to show that this link also extends
to children as well and say one study
saw that three-year-olds who sleep
that's less than 10 and a half hours a
night had a 45 percent increased risk of
obesity by age seven and just one final
study that I'll share with you just to
end off this video and stay to the group
of overweight men and women and with all
of them on a low-calorie diet for two
weeks but one group were allowed to
sleep five and a half hours per night
whilst the other were allowed eight and
a half hours per night so babe all the
groups lost weight through the dieting
but remarkably what they saw was the
group that only slept five and a half
hours more than 70% of their weight loss
came from lean body mass which is muscle
not fat was for the group who slept
eight and a half hours more than 50% of
the weight loss came from fat which is
the ideal situation for weight loss so
as we came back to
this graph I'll just summarize that what
we've seen is that if you have short
sleep not only does your hunger and
appetite increase you also compromise
the impulse control and your cravings
and therefore increase food consumption
and you also prevent effective weight
loss so hopefully you've learnt
something and I promise I'll do a review
on this book when I finish it and as
always thanks for listening